مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابع من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوي
[موسيقى]
بصعوبه الوضع في الخطوط الاماميه في
باخموت والحرب تطغى على المحادثات الصينيه
الاوروبيه
المركز السعودي للتخسيس يتيح 200 مشروع
للمستثمرين شركات في البنى التحتيه
والمجتمعيه
العربيه تواكب عوده الرحلات المباشره بين
اربيل وجده تسهيلات مستمره للمعتمرين
العراقي
في الرابعه ايضا
400 متطوعه صحيه في المسجد الحرام اسعافات
اوليه على مدار الساعه للمعتمرين والمصلين
المح الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
لا امكانيه سحب القوات الاوكرانيه من
باخمت وقالت بمؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره
البولنديه ان الوضع يزداد صعوبه في الخطوط
الاماميه في باخ حيث تدور معارك دارها
مشيرا الى ان الاولويه ستكون لحفظ ارواح
الجهد اضف زيلينسكي انه سيتخذ القرار
المتناسب مع ازدياد الموقف تعقيدا
حيث قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
خلال زيارته الى الصين ان الحرب التي
تقودها روسيا في اوكرانيا اثرت بشكل عميق
على النظام الدولي وانتهكت ميثاق الامم
المتحده ودعا ماكرون صيني الى لعب دور
اكبر في هذا الملف بسبب علاقاتها الوطيده
مع روسيا
قادتها روسيا في اوكرانيا بشكل عميق على
النظام الدولي الذي عرفناه منذ عام
1945 هذه الحرب التي وصفتها مرارا وتكرارا
بانها امبرياليه واستعماريه انتهكت العديد
من مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده والتي يجب
علينا الدفاع عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين
على وجه التحديد ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا
قال رئيس الفرنسي ايضا ايمانويل ماكرون
على اهم الشي زيارته الى الصين هو ليس من
مصلحه الصين استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا
موضحا بانه لم ياتي الى الصين للتفاوض
بشان السلامه في اوكرانيا لان بكين ستساعد
في هذا الشان على حد وصفه كما شدد ماكرون
على انه في حال قيام الصين بتسليح روسيا
فانها ستصبح بذلك متواطئه في خلق القانون
الدولي اقتصاديا نكد الرئيس الفرنسي على
ان المخاطر الاقتصاديه التي تواجهها بلاده
لا يعني عدم او ما تعني عدم القيام باي
عمل تجاري معصى
قد اكد رئيس روسيا ان روسيا تظلم منفتحه
على علاقات شراكه بناء مع اي دوله ولم
تعزل نفسها وشرى خلال اعتماد اوراق عدد من
السفراء الاجانب الجدد ومن بينها سفيره
الولايات المتحده اشار الى ان العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده تمر بازمه عميقه وان
التدخلاتها لدعم الانقلاب في اوكرانيا عام
2014 تسببت في الوضع الراهن مشان العلاقات
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي قال بوتين انها
تدهورت بشكل خطير بسبب ممارسات عدائيه
معربا عن امله في انهائها قريبا وطلب
بوتين الدنمارك بدعم المقترح الروسي
لانشاء لجنه التوقيت او لجنه للوقوف على
ملابسات التفجير خطاي انابيب
من باريس الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور محمد سيف الدين دكتور محمد مرحبا
بك
ما هي الدلالات هذه الزياره في هذا
التوقيت من قبل الرئيس الفرنسي الى الصين
بصحبه رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسنال
نعم التوقيت توقيت هذه زياره مهم جدا
وحساس جدا وياتي في في وضع يعني تنظر كل
القوى العالميه الى الاحداث في اوكرانيا
بشكل كبير جدا والى الموقف الصيني بعد
زياره الرئيس الى موسكو قبل اسبوعين
الجميع ينظر الى احتمالات تطور الموقف في
اوكرانيا ومن خلال الصراع الدائر بين
الصين والولايات المتحده بشكل كبير والذي
يطبع العلاقات الدوليه الراهنه وسوف يستمر
بذلك الى الى سنوات مقبله الرئيس الفرنسي
لديه مجموعه من الاهداف من هذه الزياره هو
كان حاول في السابق مع اندلاع المواجهه في
اوكرانيا
يشرع في وساطه مع الرئيس الروسي او يحاول
يعني يوقف الحرب في بدايتها الرئيس
الفرنسي اليوم والاوروبيين بشكل عام
يعرفون بانهم من اكثر القوى التي تلقت
خسائر جراء هذه المواجهه خسائر ليست فقط
بالمساعدات التي قدموها هناك خسائر اخرى
متعلقه بتدهور الوضع الاقتصادي هناك وسائر
متعلقه بالدوري الاوروبي الذي اصبح مهددا
في العالم الجديد الذي يتشكل الان
وبالتالي هناك رغبه ضمنيه من الرئيس
الفرنسي بان يشبك مع الصين للسنوات
المقبله بان يلحق بركاب القطار الذي انطلق
والذي سوف يتشكل من خلاله النظام الدولي
الجديد
في العلاقه الان بين باريس وبكين ما هي
السيد او دكتور محمد يعني
وماذا تعني الرئاسه الفرنسيه عندما تشير
في بيانها الى ان الزياره تاتي لاعاده
تعديد اعاده تحديد المعايير في العلاقات
بين البلدين
نعم في في الفتره الماضيه التزمت فرنسا
ومعها القوى الاوروبيه في خفض هذه
العلاقات او البقاء يعني بضمن التوجه
الحذر بالتواصل مع الصين الان اعتقد ان
الامور اصبحت يعني وفق ما ذكرتموه المعاني
تشير الى ان الامور اصبحت اكثر الحاحا على
القوى الاوروبيه من اجل التواصل مع الصين
لان عدم التواصل سوف يضعهم في يعني في في
موقف متاخر هناك الكثير من القوى
الاقليميه والقوه الصاعده سبقت اوروبا
والاوروبيين في التواصل مع الصين وفي مد
شبكات لهذا التواصل وتاسيس منهجي ومؤسساتي
لهذا التواصل وهناك مجموعه بريكس وهناك
السعوديه وايران في في الخليج هناك تركيا
ايضا هناك الهند هناك قوه اخرى يعني تحاول
ان تشبك مع لغه العالم الجديد وتتحدث هذه
اللغه وتشبك مصالح للمستقبل الاوروبيين
الان يريدون ان يقوموا بذلك ويردون خساره
فرصهم في المستقبل هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى
يجب ان ان نشير الى ان فرنسا والاوروبيين
ايضا لا يريدون المخاطره في هذه اللحظه
الحساسه التي يعرفون بان اي خطوه متسرعه
في هذا الشان ممكن ان تؤدي الى خسائر
كبيره جدا لا يريدون التسرع في خساره
الثقه الامريكيه وبالتالي هو هو يتحرك من
ضمن السياق ضمن التحالف الالعابر للاطلسي
لكن مع رغبات داخليه عميقه بان تدخل
اوروبا وتدخل فرنسا باتجاه الجديد هل
فرنسا الان تذهب بالفعل الى موازنات
العالم الجديد كما قلت ام ان الامر يتعلق
بمحاوله فرنسيه ربما لاغراء الصين بفك
الارتباط بين بكين وموسكو
نعم هذا تماما ما ودت الاشاره اليهم هم
بالتاكيد الرغبه العميقه والداخليه والتي
تعبر عن المصالح الاوروبيه وعن المصالح
الفرنسيه الداخليه وهذا امر عبروا عنه
بشكل واضح هنا حينما قالوا ان فرنسا
واوروبا لديهم مصالح مختلفه عن المصالح
الامريكيه اذا المحرك الداخلي لهذا الزخم
ولهذا الجهد الجديد هو المصالح الفرنسيه
والاوروبيه لكن من جهه اخرى لا يمكن نسيان
الارتباط الامني والارتباط الحضاري
والارتباط بالتحالف بين اوروبا وفرنسا
والولايات المتحده وبالتالي جزء من
الاهداف المباشره لهذه الزياره سوف يكون
الحديث عن اوكرانيا ومحاوله الفصل بين
روسيا والصين خصوصا بالنواحي العسكريه هم
في هذا المعنى عندما عندما تذهب
ويسحب كذلك الرئيس الفرنسي مجموعه من
التجار برجال الاعمال ايضا مدراء شركات
كبيره ايضا فرنسيه زياره تستغرق ثلاثه
ايام يعني ذلك بانه الشرط ربما لاعاده
العلاقات بزخم اكبر خلال فتره القادمه
والاستثمار اتاحه الاستثمار الصيني في في
فرنسا والعكس كذلك ومرتبط بالموقف الصيني
من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
هو ليس شرطا حاسما في هذا السياق السياسه
الخارجيه الفرنسيه وخصوصا الدبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه الرئاسيه دائما تمشي على هذا
النسق يصطحب معه رجال الاعمال الى كل
الدول التي يزورها في هذه الفتره اتحدث
وهو يحاول يعني المجيء بعقود كبيره
للشركات الفرنسيه فرنسا لا ننسى انها خسرت
الكثير في افريقيا في الفتره الراهنه في
الاشهر الماضيه تحل قوه اخرى محلها
وبالتالي الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه تحاول
ايجاد مصادر اخرى
لمتابعه النمو الاقتصادي والخروج من
الازمه الاقتصاديه هذا من ناحيه لكن موقف
فرنسا وثقل فرنسا الحالي لا يخولها بان
طفر الشروطا على الصين لموازنه هذه الشروط
مع العلاقات الاقتصاديه من يستفيد اكثر من
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين الطرفين هو
الاوروبيين الان ليست الصين الصين لديها
استراتيجيه واضحه تقوم على خمس نقاط وهذه
الخمس نقاط اعتقد انها ليست بحاجه لفرنسا
في في تنفيذها بعض هذه النقاط يرتبط
بالتطوير الداخلي يرتبط باستعاده الشرعيه
التاريخيه في تايوان يرتبط بتطوير ما تصفه
الصين السياده التكنولوجيه تريد الصين عدم
الحاجه التكنولوجيه الى في العصر المقبل
وايضا تطوير قوه بحريه عسكريه قادره على
حمايه الطموحات الصينيه والحصول على مصادر
الطاقه شكرا جزيلا لك في العلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور محمد سيف الدين من باريس
بعد شهرين من الكارثه استمرار وصولي
وتوزيع المساعدات السعوديه على متضرر
الزلزال في سوريا
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه رجال الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز بصرف معونه شهر رمضان
للمستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي بمبلغ الف
ريال العقل وخمسمائه ريال للتابع من
المنتظر ايداع مبالغ المعونه التي تقدر
باكثر من ثلاثه مليارات ريال في الحسابات
البنكيه للمستفيدين بشكل مباشر خلال
الساعات المقبله
رفعت وكاله تصنيف الائتماني للسعوديه من
درجه
مستقبليه مستقره او من اي الى اي بلاس
واستندات في قرارها الى القوه الماليه
للمملكه وضبط الدين العام وتوقعت استمرار
التقدم الحالي في الاصلاحات الماليه
والاقتصاديه والحوكمه كانت وكاله موديلز
استاندرد اند بورز قد اصدرته قبل اسبوعين
تقريرهما عن تصنيف السعوديه الائتمانيه
واكدت مودز تصنيف المملكه عند اي واحد مع
تعديل النظره المستقبليه من مستقره الى
ايجابيه
ايضا في السعوديه حدد المركز الوطني
للتخسيس 200 مشروع متاح للمستثمرين
المحليين والدوليين وذلك بهدف اتاحه
الفرصه لهم للتعرف على مشاريع التخصيص في
المملكه وطبيعتها قبل فتره كافيه من طرحها
رسميا للسوق بدوره دعوى وزير الماليه
السعودي محمد الجدعان الى الاستمرار في
نشر المشاريع
لتعزيز الشراكه بين القطاعين العامه
والخاص وجدت باستثمارات دوليه جديده
واستفاده القطاع الخاص المحلي من الفرص
المعلن عنها
وكشف الرئيس التنفيذي للمركز السعودي
للتخصيص مهند باسودان للعربيه ان الكثير
من المشاريع سيتم طرحها خلال الفتره
المقبله منها مطارات وطرق سريعه اضافه الى
مستشفيات عامه وجامعيه وغيرها من المشاريع
ايضا فيه مشاريع جدا كبيره ومهمه مثل
مباني مدرسيه كذلك كليات التميز من خلال
اقامه مباني ومشات نموذجيه ايضا من المهم
جدا الاشاره انه راح يكون في توسع في
مشاريع المياه بالاضافه يعني مشاريع انتاج
المياه المحلاه ومعالجه الصرف الصحي تم
الحمد لله خلال الفتره الخريبه الماضيه
طرح مشاريع الخزنه الاستراتيجي للمياه
خطوط النقل وجميعها راح تشحن باذن الله في
الامن المائي كما اشار الرئيس التنفيذي
للمركز السعودي للتخسيس مهند باسودان الى
ان اكثر من 60 مشروعا حاليا في مراحل
التطوير وكل مشروع منها له جدول زمني محدد
في مشاريع الان موجوده في
السوق تم طرح خلافه الماضيه ما يقارب 60
مشروع موجوده الان طرحت للمستثمرين في
اكثر من مشروع من 60 مشروع تقريبا في
مراحل تطوير وثيقه الاعمال البزنس كيسز في
مراحل اوليه في بعض المشاريع ايضا موجوده
بعض المشاريع في مراحل دراسه الاحتياج
فكلها في مشاريع متنوعه
ومراحل مختلفه ومتاحه تفاصيلها اكثر على
على الموقع وكل مشروع له جدول زمني محدد
بعد مرور نحو شهرين من وقوع الزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا لا تزال المساعدات التي
تقدمها السعوديه
لمتضرر الزلزال تتدفق الى هذه المناطق
اخرها اعلان مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه توزيعه 43 طن و28 كلغ
من السلال الغذائيه لمتضرري الزلزال في
محافظه ادلب شمال سوريا واوضح المركز ان
نحو 400 اسره استفادت منها في مدينتي ادلب
وحارم مضيفا بان هذه المساعدات تاتي
امتدادا للجهود الاغاثيه والانسانيه التي
تقدمها السعوديه عبر المركز لاغاده الدول
المتضرره في مختلف الازمات
الرحلات الجويه بين اربيل وجده واقلعت اول
طائره من مطار اربيل الدولي الى مدينه جده
السعوديه عبر الناقل الجويه السعودي
172 مسافرا بين معتمر وسائح ومن المتوقعان
يكون الجدول الرحلات مسجلا بواقعي رحلتين
اسبوعيا من مطري اربيل جده وبالعكس كمرحله
الاولى
نائب القنصل السعوديه في اربيل خالد
الشمراني اكد ان استئناف الرحلات الجويه
بين اربيل وجده ياتي ضمن اطار العلاقات
المشتركه مشيرا الى ان السعوديه تعمل على
تسهيل دخول الزوار الى اراضيها
تاتي هذه الخطوه في اطار العلاقات الطيبه
التي تربط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بجمهوريه العراق واقليم كردستان حيث تحرص
حكومه سيدي خادم حريمي الملك سلمان ابن
عبد العزيز ال سعود وصاحب السمولكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء حفظهم الله على باتل
جميع الامكانات التي من شانها ان تسهل
دخول الزوار الى اراضي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الزميل سعود الخلف ايضا وكب وصوله 172
مسافرا الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز من
اربيل نتابع
استانفت الرحلات الدوليه المنتظمه بين
السعوديه والعراق برحله قادمه من مطار
اربيل الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده
وعلى متنها اكثر من 170 مساكنه
[موسيقى]
الفرحه يعني واحد ما يقدر يوصف يعني
الفرحه جياشه والمشاعر جياشه يعني سعداء
جدا مسرورين واستقبلونا حتى بدايه المطار
يعني ما شاء الله عليهم رحبوا بينا وكذا
وقدمونا حتى هدايا نشكرهم والله نشكركم
جدا
[موسيقى]
سترتبط الرحلات الجويه المباشره والمنتظمه
بين جده واربيل بمعدل رحلتين اسبوعيا
وسيتم مضاعفه هذا العدد خلال الشهر المقبل
[موسيقى]
الفرحه مالتي متى نوصف لا من نجحت ولا من
تخرجت من الرزقه الاطفال ولا من تزوجت ولا
من صار عندي بيت ولا من صار عندي مال وذهب
ابد فرحه ما اعرف ما اعرف اوصفها نسيت
اولادي وبقتي وهي بس اريد اجي
[موسيقى]
رحلات الدوليه بين السعوديه والعراق هو
نتيجه للجهود المبذوله من مجلس التنسيق
السعودي العراقي والتي تهدف لتعزيز
العلاقات الاقتصاديه وتنميه التبادل
التجاريه بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
رابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل
رابع تواكب موسم جني المانجو في جيزان
جنوبيه السعوديه مليون شجره وعوائد ضخمه
بصعوبه الوضع في الخطوط الاماميه في
باخموت والحرب تطغى على المحادثات الصينيه
الاوروبيه
مركز السعوديه للتخصيص يتيح 200 مشروع
للمستثمرين شركات في البنى التحتيه
والمجتمعيه
العربيه تواكب عوده الرحلات المباشره بين
اربيل وجده تسهيلات مستمره للمعتمرين
العراقيين
و400 متطوعه صحيه في المسجد الحرام
اسعافات اوليه على مدار الساعه للمعتمرين
والمصلين
اهلا بكم من جديد 400 متطوعه صحيه بالحرم
المكي يعملنا او تعملنا برفقه الهلال
الاحمر السعودي في موسم العمره داخل
المسجد الحرام لخدمه المصلين والمعتمرين
وتقديم كافه الاسعافات الاوليه لهم عند
الحاجه
[موسيقى]
رمضان وموسم العمره تتسارع فيه القلوب
والخطى لاعمال الخير والتطوع جمانه جوهرجي
اختصاصيه تمريض قطت
630 ساعه تطوع صحي طوال ثلاثه اعوام وجدت
ذاتها في مساعده وعلاج المعتمرين والمصلين
بالحرم المكي
انسانه تحب شغلها وحب التطوع بشكل دائم
واحب انزل بشكل يومي فنحن نتنقل مواقع
مختلفه عشان نكسب خبره من كل مكان ويتم
توزيعنا في جميع انحاء العرب كل فخر اني
انا بتطوع في الحرم المكي الشريف عشان انا
بكسب اجره ثواب من الله عز وجل وكمان عشان
اقوي يعني ثقافه الصحيه في المجال تبعي
400 متطوعه صحيه طعمنا برفقه الهلال
الاحمر السعودي يجبنا المسجد الحرام طوال
شهر رمضان لتقديم الاسعافات الاوليه
المختلفه
ومعالجه الاصابات دون مقابل مالي الهلال
الاحمر تقريبا ثلاث دورات تاهيليه عشان
ننضم لموسم الحج والعمره بالاضافه للدورات
اللي احنا اخذناه سابقا زي سفير الحياه
المستجيب الاول اللي اهلتنا اننا نقدم
الاسعافات الاوليه لضيوف الرحمن بحكم
مختلف الجنسيات الموجوده في الحرم المكي
في كل فرقه فينا عندها لغه اضافيه يعني
عضو يتكلم ويترجم للفرقه باللغه اضافيه
فانا اتحدث اللغه العربيه والتركيه
والانجليزيه
تتعاملوا هؤلاء الفتيات المتطوعات مع ما
يتجاوز 70 حاله اسعافيه يوميا بالحرم
المكي وساحات وتنوعت الحالات بين ضربات
الشمس ومعالجه الجروح والانعاش القلبي من
الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي العربيه
ونبقى ايضا في مكه المكرمه حيث اطلقت
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين مجموعه من الدراسات
الهندسيه والفنيه بالتاكد من جوده منظومه
الخدمات المقدمه للمعتمرين والزور اضافه
الى فعاليه وكفاءه الانظمه التشغيليه
والخدميه والتي منها انظمه التكييف
والتلطيف المناخي وشبكات الاتصالات
والشاشات الالكترونيه بجانب الانظمه
السمعيه والبصريه يتم تنفيذ هذه الدراسات
على المستفيدين داخل المسجد القياسي مدى
جوده الانظمه والجاهزيته
من الحرم المكي الشريف ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه هانس هاني مرحبا كيف يتم العمل
وتنفيذ هذه الدراسات
نعم اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا من خلال كاميرات العربيه
التي نرصدها ونشاهد فيها حركه المعتمرين
وكذلك ايضا هي تعطي طابع لمدى رضاهم وكذلك
الخدمات المقدمه في المسجد الحرام طبعا
هذه الدراسات التي نفذت رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين والتي تقوم على قياس جوده الخدمه
وجوده ايضا الانظمه التي نفذت رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين سواء الانظمه السبعيه او البصريه
او كذلك التلطيفيه وايضا كيفيه الخدمات
المقدمه لدى المعتمرين والزوار هنا في
المسجد الحرام عموما المهندس عبد الله
الحريقي وهو وكيل مساعد للدراسات
والمشاريع الهندسيه مرحبا بك مهندس عبد
الله في نشره الرابعه العربيه ونتكلم
اليوم عملتهم عده دراسات نوعيه وكذلك
دراسات عامه دعنا نتحدث كم جرام من عمليه
من استبيان
لتاكد من وقياس الخدمات المقدمه في رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين تحديدا في المسجد الحرام
وكذلك مدى رضا حياك الله اخوي يا هلا
وسهلا نرحب فيكم الحقيقه من قلب المسجد
الحرام بالتوازي مع ما طلقتها الرئاسه
العامه من خطط تنفيذيه وخدميه تسعى لتطوير
المرافق والاصول جاب التوازي معها جانب
الدراسات والابحاث الحقيقه طلقنا مجموعه
من الدراسات الهندسيه التي تهدف ان تقيس
مدى رضى خدمه الضيوف بيت الله الحرام عن
الخدمات المقدمه لهم والانظمه الاساسيه
سواء كانت انظمه ارشاديه انظمه انظمه
التكييف والاناره تجهيزات الهندسيه
بالكامل عملنا دراسه هندسيه
مسحنا اكثر من 600 شخص قبل الموسم عفوا
600 شخص الى 700 شخص قبل موسم للتاكد من
رضاهم على الخدمات المقدمه لهم جوانب
التطوير المستهدفه الاماكن اللي تحتاج
مزيد تطوير مزيد عنايه افضل نقاط القوه
اللي احنا ممكن نركز عليها ومن هذه
المنطلقات كان في اكثر من خطط ومشروعات
نوعيه اعلن عن هل تحقق الرضا بالنسبه
لعمليه 700 شخص نعم نعم كانت في نسبه
تجاوزت 92% ولله الحمد اليوم احنا نعمل
على تطوير
الجوانب اللي كانت تحتاج الى مزيد عنايه
ومزيد رعايه بالتكاتف مع كل شركاء النجاح
اللي موجودين معانا في المنظومه التشغيليه
لعلي اذكر على سبيل الذكر احد الدراسات
النوعيه اللي اطلقناها دراسه الوصول
الشامل تطوير معايير وصول الشامل هدفنا
الرئيسي من الدراسه انه بغض النظر عن
الخلفيه الثقافيه للضيف والزائر وسماتهم
وخصائصهم الطبوغرافيه الكل يتاح له الوصول
للخدمه وتفسير العطاء بحيث انه الخدمه
تكون متاحه لكل شخص مهندس عبد الله بينما
ايضا نحن نتحدث عن عمليه قياس جوده الخدمه
المقدمه للمعتبرين الكاميرا العربيه ايضا
من خلال الكاميرات هي ترصد عمليه حركه
المؤتمرين وكذلك في الساحات الخارجيه
ونشاهد ايضا عمليه ثلاثه عمليه التنظيم هل
هي داخله في عمليه الدراسه التي
تم تنفيذها من قبل او طرح طرحتها رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين قطعا دراسه وجود الانظمه
بالتوازي مع الحركات والمسارات والممرات
كذلك التي تهيا من خلال تخصيص عده وكالات
عندنا المراكز البحثيه وعندنا وكالات خاصه
بالحشود تعمل الكل يعمل في تكاتف وتناغم
حتى مع الزملاء في شركاء النجاح بحيث انه
كل المسارات تكون بسلاسه حركه بالتوازي
يكون هنالك كل الخدمات متاحه وميسره لهذه
الفئه اللي هم ضيوف بيت الله الحرام في
الموسم شكرا لك مهندس عبدالله اذا المهندس
عبدالله تحدث عن دراسات عده واستبيانات
نفذتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين وبينما ايضا
هناك جهات تعمل من قبل الامنيه وايضا لو
نلتقط بعض الصور التي تقوم بها الجهات
الامنيه فهنا
قوه الدعم في الحرم المكي من قبل الدفاع
المدني وكذلك هناك شاشات خصصه للمعتمرين
والزوار كي ترشدهم وايضا تقوم بتوجيههم
لاماكن التي يرغبونها والاستفسار وتجيب
على الاستفسارات التي يحتاجونها تفضل
خلينا ايضا نذهب
نرى الصوره كذلك في المدينه المنوره امام
الحرم النبوي الشريف ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه السلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك
سلطان ايضا كيف ترصد لنا المشهد الان في
المسجد النبوي الشريف واهم الخدمات
المقدمه للزوار
مسجد رسول الله عليه الصلاه والسلام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه نتحدث عن نحو قرابه 13 مليون
مسلقه باداء الصلواتنا في المسجد النووي
النبوي تحدثنا عن تنفيذ اكبر خطه تشغيليه
يشهدها المسجد النبوي اليوم في هذا الموسم
بعد استقبال كافه المصلين باعداد قصوى
وتشغيل المسجد النبوي كامل الطاقه
لاستعابيه نقف الان في الساحه وتحديدا
امام باب 335 للتو انتقاموا المصلين باداء
صلاه العصر وهنالك عمليات للتفويج من خلال
مسارات للدخول ومسارات للخروج في المسجد
النبوي بشكل كبير هنالك نحو 300 340 الف
مصل يقومون يشهدون الحرم المكي يوميا هنا
في المسجد الحرام وتزيد هذه النسب مع صلاه
التراويح وصلاه الفجر تحديدا تم فتح كافه
الابواب وفتح كافه المسارات المؤديه الى
المسجد النبوي لاستقبال المصلين لاداء
الصلوات ايضا اتحدث الارقام كبيره يشهدها
او تشهدها الروضه الشريفه نتحدث عن اكثر
من 36 الف تصريح يومي يستطيع من خلاله
الزائرون زياره الروضه الشريفه نتحدث على
خمسين في المئه منهم للنساء وخمسين في
المئه للرجال عبر هذه السته وثلاثين الف
التصريح نتحدث الاكثر من 82 الف وجبه توزع
يوميا هنا في المسجد النبوي نتحدث ارقام
كبيره تعمل عليها رئاسه الشؤون المسجد
النبوي هذا الموسم لاستقبال اكبر عدد ممكن
مصلين والتعامل مع كافه الحشود والتدفقات
البشريه التي يشهدها المسجد النبوي
وتحديدا في اثناء اداء صلوات التراويح
وتحديد صلاه العشاء والتراويح وصلاه الفجر
نتحدث اليوم من المدينه المنوره تشهد
اعداد كبيره من المصلين من كافه الجنسيات
اليوم نشاهد الجنسيات الاسيويه والعربيه
وغيرها من الجنسيات التي يحرصون على زياره
المسجد النبوي بعد اداء مناسك العمره ومن
ثم زياره المدينه المنوره للصلاه في
المسجد النبوي وزياره الروضه الشريفه ايضا
التحدث خدمات كبيره في المنطقه المركزيه
المقابله للمسجد النبوي من خلال تجهيزها
بالمطاعم والمقاهي وغيرها من الخدمات
الكبيره لاستقبال المعتمرين والعفو
لاستقبال المصلين والزائرين بشكل مستمر
هنا في المسجد النبوي ايضا يتحدث على
توزيع وجبات الافطار المجانيه واكثر من
400 طن يوميا تاتي من مكه الى المسجد
للمسجد النبوي
لتوزيع عبوات زمزم وكذلك تعبئه المشربيات
وكذلك حافظات مياه زمزم شكرا جزيلا لكم
مائدا من المدينه المنوره مراسل العربيه
السلطان السلمي ومن الحرم المكي الشريف
مراسل العربيه هاني الصياد يعطيكم العافيه
ونعود الى مكه حيث يعمل المواطن سلطان
المالكي احد سائقيه حافلات مكه على نقل
الاف المعتمرين والزوار الى المسجد الحرام
بشكل مجاني
[موسيقى]
هو يعرفها عن ظهر قلب يقول ان القياده في
شوارع مكه بالحافله لا تختلف كثيرا عن
السير في طرقاتها كما اعتاد ذلك صغيرا
اتشق سلطان المالكي طريقه حتى استطاع ان
يقود فريقا من السعوديين العاملين في
قياده حافلات مكه مشروع نقل الاهم في
العاصمه المقدسه حافلات مكه وليها الان
فيها تقريبا سنتين تدرجت فيها كسائق حافله
من ثم انتقلت الى التدريب قسم التدريب
انتقلت الى الاشراف وما زلت فيها عمل قيم
وشيء يعني يحفز النفس يعني شيء
جميل جدا انك تكون في خدمه ضيوف الرحمن
الى جانب المعتمرين والزوار يستفيد العديد
من الاهالي من خدمات هذا المشروع الذي
يربط بين نواحي مكه حيث يحتوي المشروع على
مئات المحطات والحافلات كما يضم عددا
كبيرا من السعوديين ضمن طواقمه المختلفه
لما تكون في الميدان طلع موهبتك
تنبسط في ضيوف الرحمن في خدمتهم يكون عملك
ميداني افضل من المكتب يعني بالنسبه لي
انا 37 مليون راكب عبر حافلات مكه منذ بدء
المشروع وحتى اليوم اذ اصبح هذا المشروع
بعد اكتماله
ركيزه اساسيه في العمليه التنظيميه لموسم
العمره مع ازدياد اعداد المعتمرين والزوار
عاما بعد عام من مكه المكرمه اسامه القاسم
العربيه
موسم جني المانجو الفاكهه الاشهر في جازان
في جنوب السعوديه يبدا هذه الايام حيث
يجني المزارعون الاف الاطنان لنشرها في
السوق المحلي او لتصديرها مليون شجره
مانجو في جازان وفق اخر الاحصائيات ومنذ
انطلاق النسخه الاولى من مهرجان المانجو
السنوي تنتج ما يزيد عن 65 الف طن سنويا
من صبيا في جيزان ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد
الرحمن وحيا الله الصبيه
وريحه صبيا ومانجا جيزان في اصناف جديده
الموسم
طبعا خالد احنا بين ارضكم وجمهورك انا
عارف انت يعني حجم حبك وشوقك المنطقه
جيزان وفعلا جيزان منطقه يعني تعشق جدا
وخاصه بها وكما قال الشاعر مثل صبيا في
الغواني ما تشوف ففعلا كل شيء هنا جميل
وغاني ومتميز وعلى راسها طبعا خالد
المانجو المانجو الذي بدات زراعته من
السبعينات ميلاديه بعد ان تم جذب بعض
الاشجار من دوريه مصر العربيه الى جيزان
ونجح نجاح مبهر وبدا يزيد مع الوقت طبعا
بعض المزارع بدات بالجني من شهر مارتش
الماضي والان ايضا بدا الجني في هذه
المزرعه الموجوده على تخوم صبيا ساده
زميلي بعض اللقطات الان هذا المزارع كما
نشاهد يبدا بجني المانجا بهذه الطريقه
التي
[موسيقى]
العصا بالضبط نعم وهذا لونه غريب يا خالد
لانه بنفسجي
اخضر مع شويه اصفر فمميز جدا هذا اللون
طبعا اذا ما تحدثنا خالد عن عدد الاشجار
فعلا الاشجار تجاوز عددها تقريبا اكثر من
مليون شجره جيزان كانت تنتج في عام 2005
18 الف طن سنويا لكن العامل الماضي وصل
الانتاج الى 65 الف طن وهذا رقم كبير جدا
ومن ضمن مستدافات رؤيه 2030 ان يزيد العدد
اكثر فاكثر خلال السنوات القليله المقبله
طبعا هناك مركز الابحاث الزراعيه التابع
لوزاره الزراعه هذا المركز يقوم ايضا بجهد
كبير مع المزارعين خالد لزياده ثقافتهم
الزراعيه وايضا محاوله زراعه انواع جديده
يعني من المتوقع ايضا الموسم هذا خالد
نشوف المشمش نشوف انواع اخرى من الفواكه
الاستوائيه لان اجواء جيزان تقريبا مشابهه
للاجواء الاستوائيه في جزر الشرق اسيا
وايضا جنوب افريقيا طبعا هناك ايضا برامج
يعني كثيره تقوم بها وزاره الزراعه مع
المزارعين لمحاوله تقديم الابحاث
والدراسات المفيده لهم وتحليل ايضا التربه
والمياه لتحديد خالد ما هي التربه
المناسبه وغير المناسبه حقيقه خالد جيزان
فيها قصه نجاح كبيره للزراعه مو بس مانجو
خالد حتى البوني شراكه مع ارامكو وايضا
شركات من قطاع الخاص نجحت ايضا في زراعتها
في فيفا والدائر ومناطق اخرى نشاهد هذه
المزرعه الان هذه المانجا خالد اشوف اربع
انواع او تقريبا اربع الوان اذا صح
التعبير اكثر من نوع طبعا موجود
هذا هو الزبده استعدادا
حلو اول واحد الزبده والثاني خالد انا انا
بختبرك يا خالد
صحيح صحيح التومي والثالث الاصفر هذا
الاصفر
هذا السوداني
يا خالد
طبعا هو في اسماء يا خالد في اسماء علميه
زراعيه وفي اسماء جيزانيه هي الاربعه
انواع هذه المشهوره حاليا ربما في هذه
الفتره
في المزرعه لازم انت مو انت طالع من
المزرعه كم كرتون ما راح نسامحك فيها
انا حجيب لك النوع هذا ابشر من عيوني
ولا لا حتى شباب يعني ودهم في في مانجا
الجيزاني ما يتفوت لا طعم ولا ريحه ولا
نبي
ابشر ابو عبد الله نبي 15 كرتون للشباب في
الرياض خلاص تم وندفع نرسل لك الفلوس لا
تخاف يا عبد الرحمن عارفك ههه عرفت
حارسل لك رقم حساب
تامر امر بس قولي اذا في اذا في يعني هذه
الانواع اللي احنا تعودنا عليها في جيزان
الاربعه انواع لكن ما ادري هل في اصناف
جديده في هالسنه ممكن تدخل
السوق اتذكر زمان كان مثلا فيه المانجا
الصغار حبات الصغير اللي زي منقل فص في
مصر فما ادري اذا كان من ضمن الاصناف اللي
ممكن نشوفها في في الاسواق سنه ولا لا
مثل هذه الزراعات زي ما قلت المانجو
الصغيره او البيبي او البيبي مانجو كما
يسمونه بعض المزارعين هذا المانجو مزارع
قليله تقوم بزراعته هنا في صربيا يحتاج
الى دراسات معينه طبعا اغلب المزارع هنا
يعني حتى طريقه الزراعه طريقه التقليديه
المعتاده لكن مثل الزراعات الخاصه
والمحميات الخاصه والانتاجات الخاصه
موجوده ببعض المزارع لكن الان بدات تنتشر
بالشراكه مع وزاره الزراعه بحيث انه
يشجعون المزارعين على زراعه انواع خاصه من
المانجو وايضا انواع اخرى من الفواكه خالد
سيما الفواكه الاستوائيه التي هي اقرب
انواع الفواكه واكثرها مناسبه للتربه في
جيزان لكن
المثير للانتباه خالد انه المزارعين هنا
يعني لديهم زي ما نقول افق واسع وتقبل
للانواع الجديده بالعكس يحبون يجربون
ويفضلون انه الوزاره تقترح عليهم انواع
جديده من المانجا
زراعه طبعا هذا المانجو حقكم يا خالد
هذا هذا هذا هذا عبد الرحمن هذا عبد
الرحمن
مو يروح يعني يلف كل مكان في السعوديه
يا خالد بعد قليل حنروح نفطر ان شاء الله
مع صاحب المزرعه الشيخ يحيى
حنفطر فطور جيزاني ان شاء الله وحنحلي
طبعا وفطور وجيزاني شعبي
كل الاكلات الجيزانيه طبعا خالد هذا نوع
حجمه عجيب وكبير صراحه
شوف الحجم يعني تقريبا اكبر من مكفل اليد
بالضبط فحجمه كبير
عبد الرحمن شهيت قبل الفطور الله يهديك
يلا جيب معك بس كم كرتونه تعال لا تنسانا
شباب مستنين حتى شاهد المتروك بعد جلسه
طالع شكرا لك من صبيه في جيزان مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصي شكرا
متزال عائله الهجهوج تحافظ على مهنتها في
صناعه الحلوى القطيفيه منذ اكثر من 120
عام المزيد مع علي اللغبي
[موسيقى]
الهجهوج اسم ارتبط بصناعه الحلوى القطيفيه
منذ اكثر من 120 عاما ثلاثه اجيال توالت
على هذه المهنه وهي من العوائل القليله
التي ذات شهرتها في صناعه الحلوى شرق
السعوديه كانت الحلوى يشتغل فيها له جدي
حج عباس الله يرحمها
ثم بعدين
توارثوها الاولاد
تعلموا الاولاد من جدي وبعدين بعد بعد جدي
انا تعلمتها من الوالد اخذت المهنه من
الوالد
وتقريبا الحين هي صار لها حول تقريبا 120
سنه
وانا الحمد لله يعني يعني حاب المهنه
هادئه ورث حسين الهجهوج صناعه الحلويات عن
والديك كما حافظ عليها لاكثر من ثلاثين
عاما جلو اهتمامه هو تعليم افراد العائله
هذه المهنه حفاظا عليها من الاندفاع
الاولاد يتعلموا من من الخبره هذه يعني ما
ودي انه الشيء هذا يعني ينته للموضوع هذا
ينتهي من يوم احنا صغار تعلمنا على الحلوى
والعمه وجدي خلونا نسوي معاهم وصار عندنا
ترابط مع الحلوى شيء في شيء تختلف الحلوى
القطيفيه عن الحلوى البحرينيه في طريقته
طبخها بينما تتشابه في مكوناتها وتتم
صناعتها بشكل يدوي دون استخدام للالات
يستغرق اعدادها 45 دقيقه ويكثر الاقبال
عليها في مناسبات مثل الكركعان في شهر
رمضان والزوجات الحلوى القطيفيه المطاطيه
يعني مو زي الحلوى البحرينيه مذاقها يعني
زي المقراز يعني هذا الفرق بس بينه والله
المقادير هي نفسها يعني هذا حلوة وديك
حلوه هي تكسر عليها الطلبات ايام القرقعان
والفتره هذي يعني احيانا تقلب الجو يعني
اذا كان الجو بارد شويه تزيد يصير الطلب
بزياده يعني تصير طلبات في الاعراس يعني
حلوتهم بالحجز لما تبغى تجينا ايام الشتاء
نحجز مثلا نبغى كيلو وين نبغى ثلاثه نبغى
اربعه وكانت اسعارها قديمه في متناول اليد
من القطيف علي اللقبي العربيه
نسبه اضاءه القمر تكون ثابته 50 في المئه
دون زياده او نقصان خالد الزعاق في تقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القمر مضاء خمسين بالمئه ما يزيد ولا ينقص
وانا اشاهده هلالا وتربيعا وبدرا ففي اول
شهر يعطينا ظهره المظلم مرحله الاستصرار
وفي منتصف الشهر يعطينا وجهه المضاء مرحله
الابدار وبينهما يعطينا جنبه مراحل
الترابيع والقمر له ظهر وله وجه اظهاره لم
يشاهده الا رواد الفضاء ووجهه يشاهده جميع
الناس بزوايا مختلفه وظهر القمر لا يشاهد
البته على الرغم من انه يدور حول نفسه ليش
لان دورانه حول نفسه مساويه لدورانه حول
الارض مثل الليطوف حول الكعبه حقيقه انه
يدور حول نفسه ويدور حول الكعب وجنبه
الموازي للكعبه لا يتغير لا تصير مثل
القمر له وجهين خليك مثل الشمس له وجه
واحد وواضحه فالشمس لا تغطي
بغربال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر الهجري يبدا هلالا بعيده مغيب شمسي
غربا وينتهي هلالا قبيل شروق شمسي شرقا
كلنا نحب القمر والقمر بيحب يمين حظنا منه
النظر والنظر راح يرضي مين
[موسيقى]
ختم الرابعه بالعنوي
بصعوبه الوضع في الخطوط الاماميه في الحرب
تطغى على المحادثات الصينيه الاوروبيه
المركز السعودي للتخصيص يتيح 200 مشروع
للمستثمرين شركات في البنى التحتيه
والمجتمعيه
العربيه تواكب عوده الرحلات المباشره بين
اربيل وجده تسهيلات مستمره للمعتمرين
العراقي
و400 متطوعه صحيه في المسجد الحرام
اسعافات الاوليه على مدار الساعه
للمعتمرين والمصلين
[موسيقى]